hey guys my name is Sarah and I'm a
tasty Creator here at BuzzFeed I'm
visiting Rome today so let's make some
Roman pasta we're making pasta a la a
matriciana I got this recipe from a
local guide and she told me to hit up
the Pam Supermarket for Quality
groceries I was so excited to explore a
new market and I had to Google Translate
a lot of the food labels but it was
worth it as I was leaving this local
Italian man saw me looking a bit
confused so we came by and took
everything out of my hands and gave me
the correct items but no worries I got
everything figured out so let's start
cooking this pasta has six ingredients
and it comes together in less than 10
minutes though this is a very simple
looking pasta it came with Rich memories
and new lessons which made this dish
taste even better top it off with extra
cheese and enjoy